e
e e
my name is cat and we're glad you're
here we'd like to welcome those online
as well let's join us
[Music]
hello um we have a welcome to the table
class that will be meeting it's next
Sunday April 28th from 3: to 4:30
and that is a it'll be right here at
Saxy first it's a free class and it's um
it's a facilitated by Brett and designed
both for those that want more
information about the table and also um
for those wanting to make this their
Community
permanently um their Church home and for
more details and to
RSVP you can uh scan the QR code on the
screen or you can go to the homepage of
our website at the table
tx.org
that's the table tx.org
now as we we come into a time of
worship we exit the kingdom of
noise her
and
productivity and we now enter the
kingdom of
Silence
Stillness and
Grace now we
enter Sacred
Space a space for
prayer
worship and
adoration a space to encounter Christ
Revel ation of
God heartbeat of
creation may love find
you find
us may we all come
home thank you Cat if you guys would
stand with us we're going to get started
tonight with um raaza
Hallelujah and if you've entered this
space perhaps maybe maybe not tonight or
maybe tonight feeling that God is
against you we are here tonight to
remind one another that that is not true
that he is for us and he is with us and
he is on our side so uh you guys sing
these words and let that truth sink into
your spirit into your heart um knowing
that you are not alone you are loved by
the Creator all right
[Music]
I raise it
Hallelujah in the presence of my
enemies I raise the
Hallelujah louder than the
unbelief how raise it
Hallelujah my weapon is a
[Music]
Melody I raise the
Hallelujah Heaven comes to fight for
[Music]
me I'm going to sing in the middle of
the
storm louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises R Up From the
Ashes hope will arise
death is defeated the king is
[Music]
alive I raise the
Hallelujah with everything inside of
[Music]
me how raise the Hallelujah
and I will watch The Darkness
flee I'll raise the
Hallelujah in the middle of the
[Music]
mystery I raise the
Hallelujah Fe you lost your hold on me
yeah I'm going to sing in the middle of
the St
louder and louder you're going to hear
my Praises Ro up from
thees Hope will
arise death is defeated the king is
alive
[Music]
yeah sing a little
louder sing s a little
louder sing a little louder we're going
to sing a little
louder sing a little
louder in the presence of my enemy sing
a little
louder louder than the
sing a little
louder my weap is Mel we're going to
louder comes to fight for me sing a
little
louder I'm going to sing in the middle
of the
storm louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises rooll Up From the Ashes
hope will
arise death is defeated the king is
alive oh I'm going to sing in the middle
of the
stor louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises Roar Up From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is defeated the king is
alive yeah
[Music]
right thank you kiddos for singing with
us y'all are dismissed to your
classrooms your teachers are waiting by
the door thank you so much kids team
Kelly and Maggie I know are in class
tonight and um our Nursery volunteers
back there and other teachers just thank
you thank you thank you we appreciate
you
[Music]
guys we are going to read through the
prayers of the people tonight and um as
we go through if you would say aloud
with us we pray to you and then um we're
going to leave some space and we would
love for you to share anything that you
may be carrying into this space tonight
whether it's a name or a situation that
is heavy on your heart we just want to
lift those up before God together
knowing that he carries them with us and
that we are a community who wants to
support each other in our tough
spaces let's
pray for the city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we
pray for The Good Earth you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the widdow and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other per D difference
we pray to you for those experiencing
loss loneliness and disconnection and
for those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen we bring you the word work of our
hands and now lay it down lay it at your
feet what we've done what we built what
we
broken lay it down lay it at your
feet you hold it all Jesus you hold it
oh
[Music]
worried Hearts wearied hands weakened
bodies lay it down lay it at your
feet what we've used what we've lost
what we've
wasted lay it down lay it in
feet you hold it all Jesus you hold it
all you hold
it Jesus you hold it all
all our dreams all our plans our
Ambitions lay it down lay it in your
feet even if nothing comes to
fruition lay it down lay it at your
feet lay lay it down lay it
in
your in Luke 15 it
says now the tax collectors and has
quotations around this word sinners just
realize that for the first time today
that there are quotations there now the
tax collectors and quote unquote Sinners
were all gathering around to hear him
the Pharisees and the teachers of the
law muttered this man welcomes Sinners
and eats with
them then Jesus told them this Parable
suppose one of you has a hundred sheep
and loses one of them does he not leave
the 99 country and go after the lost
sheep until he finds it and when he
finds it he joyfully puts it on his
shoulders and goes home and then he
calls his friends and neighbors together
and says Rejoice with me I have found my
lost
sheep I tell you that in the same way
there will be more rejoicing in heaven
over one sinner who repents then over 99
right righteous persons who do
[Music]
not there's a Grace when the Heart Is
Under
Fire another way when the walls are
closing
[Music]
in and when I look at the space between
where I used to be and this
Reckoning I know I will never be
alone there was another in the
fire standing next to me there was
another in
the holding back the SE and should I
ever need
reminding of how I've been set free
there is a cross that bears the bir
where another died for me there is
another in the
[Music]
fire oh my dad left a dead beneath the
wall
[Music]
I'm no longer slave to my sin
anymore should I fall in the space
between what remains of me and this
Reckoning either way I won't bow to the
things of this world cuz I
know I know I will never be
alone there be another in the
fire standing next to me there is
another in the
water holding back the sea and should I
ever need
reminding what power Set Me Free there
is a grave that HS
nobody now the power lives in me there
is another in the
fire oh
oh there is a another in the
fire
wo there is another in the
oh there be another in the
fire
W I can see the light in the darkness as
the darkness bows to him I can feel the
RO
in the heavens has space between where I
can feel the ground shakee us as the
prison walls keep nothing stands between
us nothing stands between us
[Music]
there is no other name but the name that
is
Jesus he who was and still is and will
be through it
all so come with me in the space between
all the things unseen and this
Reckoning I know I will never be alone
oh I know I will never be
alone another in the
fire standing next to me there be never
in the
waters holding back the Seas should I
ever need
reming how good you've been to me come
the Joy from every battle cuz I know
that's where you'll be
I can see the light in the darkness as
the darkness bows to I can hear the RO
in the heavens has a space between W I
can feel the ground shake beneath us as
a Prison Walls P nothing stands between
us dance let's sing that again I can
feel the L in Darkness as the darkness
bows to hell I can hear the roar in the
heavens as space between rest I can feel
the ground sh us as a prison
W nothing stands between
us nothing stands between us another in
the
fire standing next to me there'll be
another in the
wers holding back the Seas should I ever
be in my name how good you've been to me
I'll come the Joy from every battle cuz
I know that's where you'll be be another
in the
fire standing next to
me be another in the
water holding back
SE should I ever need
reminding how good you have been to me
count the joy come every
battle cuz I know that's where you'll be
count the joy come every battle cuz I
know that's where you'll
be count the joy come
everybody I know that's where you be
yes God would you remind us
tonight that just because we're facing a
battle because we come on hard
times because we have struggles and
failures and
flaws that does not mean you have
forsaken us that does not mean you are
far from us but it is in those times
that we find you holding
us steadying
us calling us
forward you have not forsaken us you
have loved us with an everlasting
[Music]
love you have given yourself on behalf
of us
we sense that truth tonight God would
you remind our
Spirits we are not
alone you are always with us you are
always
[Music]
present we love you God because you are
a good God
you are a good
[Music]
God as Brett comes and speaks to us
tonight God would you soften our hearts
would you help us to hear your
words help us to receive them would it
be good seed that goes into fertile soil
and produces good fruit
in Jesus name
amen would you guys make the people
around you feel welcomed and at home and
then we are going to get started with
our message
well Grace and
peace it is good to be with you all um
really really glad to be with you and uh
my name is Brett and if this is your
first time or maybe just first time in a
long time we're really really glad that
you're here and I know it can take it
can just be a lot walking through those
doors especially depending on Church
background and such so um yeah so thank
you so much for coming into this into
this space um and also don't want to
forget those join us online love you all
lots too glad you're you're with us
through the wonders of the internet so
um we are in the season of uh Easter
tide right now and uh this is um kind of
a season of The Church calendar that's
basically just a continuation of Easter
just celebrating the the resurrection of
Christ and so we are um in a series
right now titled practicing Resurrection
where um we're just looking at um
passages from the book of Acts in the
early church and how they kind of lived
into and practice Resurrection Life and
so I would say this message tonight I'm
excited for it it's a little bit
spicy uh yeah so uh at least well this
is going now you're going to be
disappointed
theologically theologically spicy I'm
like that's what I find I'm like such
such a nerd I'm like oh it's a spicy one
you know and so this is the title this
is what I think is spicy um practicing
Resurrection a new kind of
evangelism and uh am I right oh
babies it's uh oh it's no I think it'll
be good so our text is from acts 4: 5-12
and it basically it builds on so last
week we looked at the story of um
there's a Man by this gate called
Beautiful who sat there every day
begging he um his legs didn't work right
and so he was kind of reduced to to
begging and there was this whole um
miracle that happened with Peter and
John they prayed for him and he was
healed and it was like a whole you know
whole thing so it kind of raised Ruckus
though and so that's the text today is
kind of the the Ruckus raised and uh and
some words that Peter said in response
so this is acts 4 uh veres 5-2 says the
next day the rulers the elders and the
teachers of the Law Men in Jerusalem uh
Anis the high priest was there so were
Caiaphas John Alexander and others of
the high priest family they had Peter
and John brought before them and began
to question them by what power or what
name did you do this then Peter filled
with the Holy Spirit said to them rulers
and Elders of the people if we're being
called to account today for an act of
kindness shown to a man who was lame and
are being asked how he was healed well
then know this you and all the people of
Israel it is by the name of Jesus Christ
of Nazareth whom you crucified but whom
God raised from the dead that this man
stands before you healed Jesus is the
stone you Builders rejected which has
become the Cornerstone salvation is
found in no one else for there is no
other name under Heaven given to
humanity by which we must be saved
so he's not mencing words is he just
coming right out and and preaching uh so
so my message tonight is going to be
centered on that um that closing line
there in verse 12 about you know no
other name under Heaven um by which we
must be saved and uh there's a a blog
post that I'm kind of drawing from it
was by a guy named um frier Aiden Kimmel
and
uh he he he kind of opened one of his
posts with this wonderful question and
he said uh what what are the
assumptions that we bring to scripture
that we do not even realize we are
bringing like what are the things we
just we do and we just assume it's it's
um it's like you can think of it as sort
of like the lenses that we wear the the
lenses not we like when you're wearing
glasses you quickly become not even
aware that they're there or like our we
contacts so it's like I'm not even
conscious that I'm seen through my
contacts you know but of course take
them off and all a sudden like oh my
gosh you know it's very obvious but you
forget that it's there in other words
it's in the same way we kind of have
these assumptions and we don't so much
just read the text for its plain meaning
um but we we're always interpreting
right and so we're bringing in certain
assumptions and uh I I think one of
those assumptions that perhaps not all
of us but many of us either still bring
or at the very least probably 90
something in this room at the very least
used to bring when we come to a text and
especially one like this it kind of it's
almost like a theological trigger like
it sort of jumps out of us is what I'm
going to call Christian
exclusivism so this is the belief that
Jesus and the apostles taught that those
who never bow the knee to Christ will
inevitably spend eternity in Hell being
consciously tormented for their sins so
like that would be the theological just
the Assumption you know what I mean like
it's just sort of there it's like in the
background maybe for many of us it's
sort of like I don't like it you know or
something in me is kind of like you know
but it's is the way it is and so I I
bring that to the text and so when we
come to something like acts
4:2 um we hear it saying that right so
for example salvation is found in no one
else for there is no other name under
heaven Heaven given to humanity by which
mean we must be saved and there's where
we make the leap right we say oh well
it's right it's right there in black and
white right could it be any clear no
other name AKA if you don't right and
this is where you can see we start doing
some quick theology in our heads like
there's no other name therefore if you
don't bow to the name so to speak you
don't submit to the name believe in the
name trust the name well then right and
you can so it's interesting how we kind
of do all of this even though of course
the this text like says absolutely
nothing about
hell does that make sense so it's it's
interesting how we right we're always
kind of putting things together kind of
filling in gaps like our brain is doing
a lot when we're when we're
reading and uh what I want to kind of
ask is what if we brought a a very
different um assumption to
scripture uh one that wasn't so much
around Christian exclusivism
um but what if it was different what if
our assumption was to kind of put it
poetically that um the weeping may last
for a
night that Joy will come in the morning
what if our assumption was that though
perhaps a soul must pass through those
purifying fires so to speak as as Paul
describes um
that in the end
[Music]
um it they really it won't be
forever but it's it we pass through and
we sort of come out the other side
healed and restored and made
whole what
if one day God really will wipe all
tears from All
Eyes what
if though like the prodal child we too
wander in this life and perhaps in some
sense even in the life to come but not
forever one day God like the good father
the good mother that she is will call
each and every single one of us
home like what if what if that was just
the default in your mind like that was
the
Assumption and then you return to texts
like this how might you hear them
differently like how might we read not
even just this text but like the whole
Bible how might we start to kind of
interpret it differently how might our
whole Christian faith start to reorient
some and as we'll get to in in a minute
um even evangelism and such you know
sharing the good news of Jesus with
others how might that start to shift so
what I'm kind of describing here is
something known as Christian
inclusivism and uh this is the belief
that God's Divine love and mercy uh
expressed through the life or Christ's
life death and Resurrection um will in
the end save all people and indeed all
creation and uh this is for for some of
us this strikes us as like a very
strange idea um perhaps even like oh
it's liberal theology Brett just jumping
out you know um but what I what actually
contend is that in the first well I
would say maybe that's like I think a
Prejudice of this age and from the the
Traditions we've come from so in the
first 500 years of Christianity this was
a much more um prevalent idea Scholars
kind of debate over there's I would say
a small number of Scholars who think it
might have actually at one time been the
more dominant position but they're I
would say on the more the margins so
it's at the very least it's been a was
is very popular you know like we know
this from something St Augustine writes
um when he actually wrote kind of
against this position and but he talks
about how this you'll find this idea all
over the place in all sorts of churches
all sorts of teachers and and such in
fact in that same blog post pror um
Kimmel he um lists uh just gives us a
long list of theologians teachers uh
folks I'm going to read these this's a
lot it's a lot of names here so these
are like you'll notice too pay attention
to like there's a lot of saints um a lot
of Bishops like it's so in other words
these aren't just like well you could
find you know 30 random Pastors in the
early church who thought this you know
like no no this is like these are some
of the big names you're like a theology
nerd you'll recognize you know some of
these names so um and this is what's
known as like Universal salvation it's
similar to Christian inclusivism
basically just a different term
Universal salvation or universalism is
kind of similar this idea all will be
safe so Bishop theophilis Clement of
Alexandria origin of Alexandria
uh the annosus purus St Anthony the
great St dianus St Gregory the
wonderworker St pimpus St Methodius uh
Bishop
uus St Hillary Bishop marcelus St aanus
macarius dimus St basil the great St
mccr St Gregory of Nissa St Gregory
Theologian everus ponus Bishop deodor
Bishop Theodore uh Bishop Titus St
Jerome rufinus St Ambrose uh St John
Cassian Bishop sinius St Maximus the
Confessor St Isaac of Nineveh uh John
scotus uh IR Eugena so it's just uh you
know my only point there is just it's
not like in other words this just isn't
Pastor Brett wearing just crazy pants
you know I feel I'm I feel pretty
comfortable I think I'm in you know
super decent decent company here and uh
and I should clarify too that you know
those thinkers it wasn't that they
rejected the idea of hell wasn't they
said like oh well that's just you know
offensive and and we're just going to
pretend Jesus didn't talk about that
it's um it was it's more nuanced than
that it's the the way they interpreted
it is in essence not as just Eternal
conscious
torment but um or maybe one way to think
of it is they they interpreted kind of
the language of Hell which Jesus of
course uses you know as a sort of um
restorative justice a healing of the
Soul as opposed to a kind of
retributive payback you know just like
oh if you mess
up get ready because the God who is love
will be torturing you for all of
eternity and even after a trillion
trillion years it's only just begun I
mean like in essence like kind of take
that in like
that's there's something about that I
don't know maybe some of you I don't
know maybe you're really down with that
I just something about it strikes me as
slightly crazy so um yeah so I think
this is it's better I think that to kind
of start to reimagine reinterpret not in
a again a way of just kind of throwing
it out or something but but re
understanding uh what we mean by this
and so um again if we had this
assumption how might we hear acts
4:2 differently right so it says
salvation is found in no one else
there's no other name under Heaven given
to humanity by which we must be saved
right we kind of read that with an
exclusivist lens and what we're kind of
emphasizing there's probably that first
part it's sort of like the no one else
and then that's again where our mind
starts running with it like oh it's sit
you're kicked out you're kicked out and
banished to Hell forever you know this
is where we start filling in but can you
hear where you could read that exact
same passage with an
inclusivist lens in other words the the
image here would be if there is any
saving to be done and I'm a Christian I
think there is saving to be done it is
Jesus who is doing the saving but even
that language towards the end by which
we must be saved can you hear how you
can bring a totally different assumption
to the exact same passage and be like
see see there it is if there's saving to
be done it's Jesus who will be doing it
that's what Peter is's preaching he's
saying it's Jesus Christ who saves right
and it's and it's us though who kind of
has to fill in which direction we're
running with it does that kind of make
sense um so this becomes yeah I think a
very uh a kind of different way to frame
not even just this passage but woo a lot
put it like that a lot in in Christian
faith um okay so it has this kind of
lead us to you know a new uh a new kind
of
evangelism and uh in other words kind of
the sharing of Jesus with others and I
think probably the key words would be
anxiety and
fear I think so much of our kind of
Evangelistic Outreach so to speak is
often at least um in lots of Christian
history has been kind of motivated by
that anxiety and fear kind of coming
back to what I said earlier you know oh
no The God Who is Love Will torture you
forever if you don't believe in Jesus
and so I'm here and it's my job to like
convince you to believe and even if you
resist even you're like I don't know if
I want to believe that I'm like oh gosh
but you have to and then we start
arguing and then we start you know I
mean like it becomes this sort of
because it's like I'm anxious because
you're like resisting and you're not
believing and I'm worried about your
Eternal salvation
and like can you just some of you're
getting anxious you describe it you know
what I mean it just becomes this sort of
w it's just just swimming like we're
just immersed in an ocean
of anxiety and
fear and when you your kind of image of
God shifts in this
way like
suddenly things change and suddenly the
way you speak to people it's it's not
because the god whose love is going to
like hurt you real bad it's it's it's no
like God loves you with an everlasting
love died on the cross rose again offers
you the Holy Spirit like offers you life
abundant like it invites you to live
into the grace and goodness and love of
God right here and right now like it
shifts drastically so and then they're
like well I don't believe that it's kind
of like okay you know okay well keep
talking or cool that's cool you know
like it can become this kind of dialogue
but it's not this kind of anxious like
what you're rejecting the mess and you
know here we are uh boy it can play in a
lot of ways like even um parent to child
this plays out you know where parents
often the anxiety keeps oh my gosh my
kids rejecting the Lord you know or
whatever and they're G you know um be in
a community with with lots of lgbtq
folks just plays out in the same way oh
my gosh you know you've come out oh no
what about this verse and that verse and
oh you're not on the right path and you
know what's what's behind a lot of that
anxiety it's like a lot of this stuff
you know so we end up trying to convince
and control and and like just imagine if
all of a sudden that like begins to
shift and suddenly we're not we're not
sharing the love of Christ with people
because we're terrified he's going to
torture them forever but but it's
actually because we think God loves all
people and wants to connect with them as
much as possible now rather than like
later you know like it's it's a a
totally different thing um in fact just
this um oh I should mention a wonderful
book on this topic trauma informed
evangelism by Charles Kaiser and Elaine
Heath it is excellent I've linked to it
in my e letter before um it is it's so
so good um because it just it kind of
unpacks the way we have to be careful
because even with kind of a new kind of
evangelism as we engage with people they
often will kind of instantly freak out
because you know we're in a
postchristian culture so it's not like
they're like Jesus who you know what I
mean like church huh Christian faith
never heard of it like no generally
people have heard in fact probably the
person you're talking to went to church
you know I mean like even if they don't
now and haven't in 20 years or whatever
and they have a whole history and
experience and this becomes it's like a
like they've experienced sort of
spiritual trauma so to speak where
they're like having bodily reactions to
you starting this convers you know what
I mean and that's why I love this book
because it's it's all about kind of
helping us kind of see this and like
learn how to talk to people as like
normal human beings and without getting
weird and anxiety you know and and
triggering and like I mean anyway it's a
it's just a wonderful wonderful um book
so let me give an example so just this
week uh I had this like fascinating
conversation I don't know if y'all get
these these messages or texts or this
one was through Facebook Messenger but
um the I'm worried for you message do
you ever get the I'm just I'm concerned
I'm worried for you I get I get these
you know fairly often um and uh and it
was amazing timing because I'm literally
uh I'm like practicing the message this
way I usually write a week ahead so I
you know wrote this last week this week
I'm like practicing it and then this
week I get this message I don't know how
this kind of friend/ acquaintance um you
know Facebook friend uh how he picked I
don't know I guess he sensed the my
Christian inclusivist leanings or
something from other posts or other you
know I don't know um and so he sent me
the I'm worried for you Facebook message
and it was fascinating because it was
just tying in with you know everything
here and it's just like man I'm just I'm
just worried for you I just you're you
know this
is It's too like in essence the kind of
part of his thing was like it's it's too
good to be true like like in Ence God's
not this nice man you know like God's
not this nice and like it was just this
whole thing and uh and he's also then
started saying like and how like what's
the motivation for evangelism for
sharing this good news if it's not fear
and Terror and and why would anyone even
be
good if this isn't sort of waiting for
them you know at the end of all things
or whatever and uh I was just like I
don't probably in the past maybe
wouldn't have even engaged much but I
think this was also on my mind and you
know he wrote me the I'm worried for you
and I was so temped to be like well I'm
worried for you you know like you're
worried for me you're the one worried
for me what are you talking about you
know what I mean I was but I tried to do
my
best stay stay chill um we had some back
and forth and I was just kind of trying
to frame it like
man like is this is this how
impoverished mainstream Christianity has
become that it's just so driven by fear
I mean I'm thinking of First John
perfect love casts out
fear like this is how we come to know
that that we really know Jesus Christ is
because no more fear no more fear like
and it's amazing how quickly we just
return to the fear
path you see to believe in the inclusive
love of God and the all encompassing
nature of Christ's saving work it does
not nullify the work of evangelism if
anything I think it actually expands
hands it opens it up like suddenly
you're able to come to people with like
truly good news not like hey good news
but if you don't believe oh my God the
worst news you've ever heard you know
instead it's just it's the good news of
Christ's saving healing work the powers
have been conquered death's been
defeated like we're invited into
Resurrection Life amazing
beautiful beautiful and it's motivating
too I mean it's I like sharing good do
this with people I don't know about you
I'm like super happy to do that uh and
it and again it makes you so sort of
normal again so human because you have
good news and you like to share it and
then if they're like not into it okay
you know that's I'm not again like oh
god well now okay I tried the nice
strategy but I've got to get them to
believe somehow so now I guess I've got
to try the I don't know the other Strate
you know whatever I'm like no no oh no
need now uh one thing I want to touch on
before we close out here is uh and it
might be a question that's on your minds
what about people though who practice a
different religious tradition you know
um because it is one thing kind of the
way I've been framing this is sort of
like a former Christian you know or
maybe someone of of kind of no religious
belief and then you're sharing the good
news and you know but how how does this
work when it's uh someone you know Comm
committed to kind of their own um their
own path uh and this gets somewhat
complex I'm probably in my e-letter this
week going to link to a few videos that
do like hour hour and a half lectures
like on this topic I don't know for the
for the the brave few who are interested
in such things um you can kind of get
into those and get more deep um because
for example I'm not I don't even
necessarily think every religious
tradition is sort of equally kind of on
the path I think there's ways to kind of
like go sideways and wander off into
highways and byways I don't know like
for example someone who's like
interested in magical powers and such
and and just you know it's almost like
God's lost and and you know so anyway
it's a little complicated but um the way
I'd like to kind of frame this is
um that I think like Peter's language
here right it does seem clear as I said
earlier if there's any saving to be done
it's Jesus Christ who's doing that
saving
maybe where we can start to open up our
mind is to kind of understand how C like
who Christ is and how his saving work
through the Holy Spirit just might be
bigger and more
expansive than we could ever have
thought possible in other words we kind
of tend to lock in on like yes it's
Jesus and it's church and it's here and
we have the truth and you better get on
board or else you are cut off from the
Lord you know and uh I I think even in
scripture there's certain verses like
for example acts 4 12 that really kind
of almost make it sound more like that
like hey it is Jesus it is this like
this is a community of the faithful and
the saved and better get on board uh but
then there's like other passages that
sort of expand the mind and such so
um Amos 9 chapter uh vers chapter 9: 7
is a perfect example of this super short
but don't don't miss the implications
this is like saying spicy this is
definitely a spicy Bible verse so this
is Amos a prophet speaking to the Jewish
people he says are not you
Israelites the same to me as the
kushites which is like already like who
wa wa wait what like no no we're not the
same to you as the we are the people of
the Lord you know
did I not bring Israel up from
Egypt the Philistines from
ctor and the arameans from
Kerr he's talking about like multiple
exoduses
here this is a spicy one this is like
mind expanding like who wait I thought
you were like in this
box and suddenly Amos is saying like m H
I think God's work is very very big in
the
world you see when I um well here let me
share one more example and this is
actually the Gospel reading uh from John
10 that's assigned to this Sunday in
addition so you have the acts passage
that we've read and then John 10 is the
other one in the lectionary it's
interesting that they chose to pair
these two um so here's John 10:1
14-16 this is Jesus speaking I the Good
Shepherd I know my sheep and my sheep
know me just as the father knows me and
I know the father and I lay down my life
for the Sheep I have other sheep that
are not of this sheep
pen I must bring them also they too will
listen to my voice and there shall
be one flock and one
Shepherd you see when I speak to people
of other
religious
Traditions I'm not speaking to them with
the assumption that they have never
heard the voice of the Good
Shepherd that they are somehow utterly
cut off from the Good Shepherd I know
Jesus I hear Christ I have the spirit
they do not you know no no and suddenly
it becomes much more of um of a dialogue
you might say that true evangelism is
actually actually rarely a one-way
Street see we speak and we are spoken to
we teach and we are taught we name what
we have learned from the voice of the
Good Shepherd and they name what they
have learned and in that process I'm not
saying that's like super simple and
straightforward and easy all the time
I'm saying in that in that
dialogue we pray and we discern and we
grow in Love For the Good Shepherd and
and like that's the kind of new kind of
evangelism that I'm envisioning not one
that's quite so us and them and I've got
the truth and you're a real idiot and my
tradition's freaking awesome and yours
is the worst you know like no no there's
um trust that God is with us Among Us
calling us all towards truth truth and
beauty and goodness uh a few book
resources uh that all shall be saved by
David Bentley Hart that one you should
know is a bit more academic it's a it's
a tough one um but very very good love
wins by Rob Bell um is a really good one
he's Visions a little bit different
that's where I prefer David Bentley
heart's kind of theology but loved ones
is still a great great read and a good
introduction on this topic um trauma
informed evangelism by Kaiser and El and
Heath that I mentioned um so yeah so if
you want more you can you can jump into
those so uh my prayer for us as we
settle more deeply into the the humility
the patience and the compassion of the
god that we've come to know in Christ is
that um that we can kind of move away
from all Notions of evangelism uh as
like a a superiority complex a kind of
dominance almost like a a creeping Rel
religious colonialism you know it's sort
of like trying to gobble up the world or
something um and in much more of like a
non-anxious vision of the
all-encompassing love that the Sheep has
or sorry that the shepherd has um for
every sheep uh every sheep in in the
Sheep pin so in the name of the Father
the Son and the Holy
Spirit
amen so as we uh as we come
to the table of the Lord tonight as we
take in the body of Christ in the bread
the blood of Christ in the wine
we we come to the inclusive God the one
who welcomes
everyone uh and thank God including us
and uh so that's kind of the heart
posture I hope that you can um
participate in in communion tonight
so um the way we'll go about this is
we'll just kind of go row by row start
here at the front and then just work our
way back we'll form a line right here um
we practice what's called an Open Table
uh meaning if you're here tonight and
something in you wants to participate
even if you're not exactly like maybe
this you know theology or this Christian
denomination or have I been baptized in
the right way or you know whatever um if
there's something you that wants to
participate then you are free to do that
you should know the red is wine and the
white is grape juice uh and then finally
you can just partake whenever and
however you'd like so some people take
immediately some folks like to kneel up
here some people return to their seats
and kind of prayerfully partake but um
no one will like lead you through the
exact you know moment of of taking and
eating and drinking so this is the table
not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
poor I spoke word you singing
you have been so so good to
me before I took a breath you breathed
your life in
[Music]
me you have been so so kind to
me how the over
overwhelming
NeverEnding Reckless Love of God oh it
chases Me Down fight till I'm found
leaves
99 and I couldn't earn it I don't
deserve it still you give yourself away
oh be
overwhelming never ending bre of God yay
y
[Music]
yay
oh when I was your fa still your love
far from me
[Music]
you have been so so good to
me when I felt no worth you paid it all
for
me you have been so so kind to me would
you guys stand with us oh the
overwhelming
NeverEnding Reckless Love of God oh it
chases Me Down fight till I found
leaves night I couldn't earn it I don't
deserve it still you give yourself away
oh the overwhelm coming
NeverEnding Reckless Love of
[Applause]
God
[Music]
o no Shadow you won't light up Mountain
and you won't climb up coming after
me sow or you won't kick down well you
won't tear down coming after
me there's no Shadow you won't light up
Mountain you won't climb up coming after
me y there's no wall you won't kick down
Li you won't tear down coming after
me no Shadow you won't light up Mountain
you won't climb up coming after
me no W you won't get down but you won't
tear down coming after me oh the
overwhelming reever ending Reckless love
God oh it chases Me Down fight till I'm
found leaves the
99 and I couldn't earn it I don't
deserve it still you give yourself away
oh the
overwhelming never ending Reckless Love
of God
[Music]
ho the
overwhelming
NeverEnding Reckless Love of God oh it
chases me down fights till I'm found
leaves the 99
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us this
evening if you are new we would love for
you to fill out a card on the table on
your way out and or scan the QR code and
on the screens and that way you can find
out more
information follow us answer any
questions we can reach out to you um and
say thank you for
visiting if you are in need of a prayer
a hug
or just general
support you may find me after the
service I would love to be there for you
in any way that I
can here at the table we are committed
to created creating a very
inclusive Christ centered community that
touches lives and generosity is a key
component of that mission if you'd like
to join us in supporting the work
financially you can scan the QR code on
the screens or in the lobby or go to our
website at the table tx.org if you
prefer you can instead share
a a personal testimony which my wife and
I have started tithing we made that
commitment and I believe that when you
do that that Christ even gives more to
you in your
life um you may not see it right away
may not can budget it right away but if
you can think about it and pray about it
um that's something we prayed very hard
about and discussed and it's very
important in the life of the
church we are using um a new sticker
system for our kids at checkout so
parents um or designated person can head
to your kids uh classroom with your
sticker to check them out after the
service
all
right let me send you into your week
with this
blessing you can hold your hands out in
in a posture position you may stand or
if you choose or
not or just open your
heart and hear these
words you are a child of
God you you are a child of
God this is true on your best
day this is true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are
worthy you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
that you come in contact
with be blessed have a good week and we
hope to see you back here next Sunday
[Music]